alors soyez le ou la bienvenue à votre
tam-tam canada j'ai quand même pas le
seul à majid et les musiques et les
fantastiques faut faire un peu d'effort
d'exercice cette semaine c'est le thème
en partie de notre émission il sera
question d'un sujet délicat n'ont pas
bonne en mai de l'embonpoint chez les
enfants juvénile et du rapport rien avec
les parents parce qu'un allié peut-être
entre les deux on va examiner la ferme
et pommeau mains puisque le sujet est
tellement sérieux on va on va repousser
les choses à l'envers le reer collectif
cette semaine notre vidéo virale de la
semaine et je vous laisse deviner pour
je vous laisse deviner vous essayez de
deviner desquels vidéo il s'agit ça
s'est passé au québec cette semaine
est-ce que je vous pouvez poser des
questions par lesquels je peux répondre
seulement par oui ou non
bon est-ce que ça a un lien avec le
sujet d'aujourd'hui c'est un lien avec
le sujet de la semaine dernière la
drogue la drogue et c'était plus que la
drogue avait l'asie l'action s'est
passée très bien jusque là
et donc c'était des jeunes qui ont
manifesté il y en a eu à ottawa jeudi en
faveur donc d'une légalisation complète
débridée la vidéo n'a pas rapport avec
ça non c'est ça vient du gouvernement
c'est le gouvernement qui a crié ça
cette vidéo la c3 vidéo à cette vidéo de
prévention pour
la consommation de cannabis voilà c'est
fait par qui a accueilli c'est quoi ça
mange quoi en hiver ça c'est crucial à
son mandat alors si vous voulez bien on
veut regarder c'est devenu viral cette
semaine ça a déclenché une pluie de
commentaires pas seulement positif mais
terriblement négatif
on va voir s'il est d'accord ou non avec
la critique de cannabis allonge le temps
de réaction
ouais on peut rouler à 130 un bateau
deux bateaux
trois bateaux ces numéros de la route
cinq bateaux six bateaux 7 bat ho8ot
deux bateaux un sportster
[Musique]
mais est-ce que ça a du sens c'est de
traiter cette question très sérieuse la
conduite avec facultés affaiblies avec
avec humour
parce que c'est ce qui a été critiqué
par beaucoup de commentaires laissés par
les québécois la principale du bourg
dans les airs au sérieux cette affaire
pourquoi tomber ça ou sous forme
d'humour mais si on compare avec les
vidéos de prévention contre l'alcool au
volant s'est dramatiquement au projet
parce que l'alcool au volant c'est
vraiment choc avec mon image de la
réalité de ce que peuvent très bien
qu'on peut mettre remettre en question
pourquoi ayant traité ce de cette façon
là je veux dire que moi personnellement
je n'ai pas d'opinion pour le moment
c'est l'impression qu'il ya c'est parce
qu'on est tellement habitué à des images
plutôt sanglante de pour ce genre de
publicité ajoute quand wade un peu du
monde et sur ce qu'on trouve que c'est
peut-être il faut se poser la question
et c'est que les pubs sanglante
fonctionne mieux
plus peut-être qu'ils ont vu que les
résultats n'étaient pas probants donc
ils ont décidé d'aller toucher une autre
arme sensible à l'humour ça fonctionne
toujours en fait il n'a peut-être pas
fonctionné au web mais c'est un
changement très brusque parce que en
fait on est habitué au québec aux
publicités vraiment sans glace ou de
mousse et je me rappelle
une publicité radio particulièrement
ceux dé la saaq sur l'alcool au volant
non sur les surveillants vola puis 10 c
un café puis ouvrir la fenêtre ouais si
vous êtes en famille ça va faire que
quand ils vont retrouve vous allez avoir
du café mélangé avec du sein puis la
fenêtre ouverte
alors c'est ça puis ça s'est très
humoristique mais ses paroles c'est pas
drôle 6 impasse sonne avec les facultés
affaiblies qui provoque un accident
piquet tue quelqu'un qu'est ce que m'a
fait bizarre on va rire parce que
c'était partie de la campagne de
prévention
ça montre encore une fois comme pepsi il
ya une couple de semaines que trouver
l'équilibré juste lorsqu'on essaie de
reprendre un message sociétal c'est pas
évident ce professionnel métiers de
publicistes et de les gens du marketing
lancée c'est vraiment une spécialité
c'est madame l'autre en façade si vous
voulez on va aller maintenant après
cette vidéo virale à notre question non
virale de la semaine de radio canada
international on pose une question
les gens répondent peu de gens la voient
je pense sur facebook c'est pas grave
l'essentiel c'est la qualité
et puis vous voulez nous rappeler la
question d'un magnifique montage le
visuel je sais pas si vous vous montrez
sa leonardo par rapport à cette question
va demander à marie claude notre
nouvelle webmestre du côté français qui
est présentement en formation ici grâce
aux conseils de leonardo de nuire cette
question et de nous donner la première
réponse qu'on a alors l'hiver est fini
le printemps arrive à grands pas
qu'attendez vous pour partir à la course
ou faire de l'exercice pour faire plus
d'exercice d'accord alors nous avons
reçu une réponse de françoise départ
dieu qui est en france elle dit j'ai
passé l'âge
à 57 ans de lever les pattes comme une
autruche et courir au grand air histoire
de perdre quelques kilos il ya trente
ans avant que mon mari ne me court après
combien de soirée perdu à faire le tour
des gymnases des gymnases elle peut
passer à la recherche du corps idéal
finalement jeudi me contenter de celui
de mon mari qui a toujours eu l'air un
peu d'une
hu a débuté avec son grand vendée ce
bourrelet de mateille depardieu lui non
plus n'a jamais eu le goût de partir à
la chasse du corps parfait et je dois
dire que comme parent on a quand même
bien transmis notre paresse ou de golf
trophy a aujourd'hui 15 ans et jérémie
qui en a trois ans de plus les
olympiques ce n'est pas pour nous sinon
un peu de vélo en famille comme en
vacances au mois d'août nous c'est pas
le prétend qu'on attend pour se lancer
mais la fin de l'été et on s'en porte
très bien merci on pourra en reparler
dans 20 ans si on n'est pas mort
d'appareils alors hors dons avant qu'on
diffuse à 11h heure de montréal notre
heure de diffusion y arrive on vous
avait dit quoi au sujet de cette dame
fait française qui nous écoutent page et
de l'amnésie je sais plus large qui l'a
traitée de grosse marée seul avec
plaisir mais oui mais madame depardieu
vous avez raison faut profiter de la vie
mais en même temps faut penser que la
vie peut être longue si on est en forme
et on peut la faire durer pas mal plus
longtemps
en fait je veux y ait un article que je
dis c'est que si encore trois heures par
semaine mais de découvrir pas pour ne
perdre du poids mation trois heures par
semaine
on peut ajouter cette jauge de vie
seulement à c'est un pacha est pas
chaque semaine qui en compte trois
mais je comprends madame depardieu moi
je ne suis pas une coureuse
par contre j'aime marcher j'aime faire
du vélo c'est sa taille ou faire du vélo
c'est de faire du sport c'est de bouger
mais même marché c'est très bon un bon
pas rapide
une heure par jour c'est pas mal du tout
non axonais mais cette madame à lundi
quelque chose il ya une vérité là dedans
c'est que des exercices de gym il faut
consacrer du temps à
oui les temps avec tes gens quand on
travaille à temps plein ou bien quand on
a des enfants
si tu mets le temps ici ça veut dire tu
te couper ailleurs mais de la volonté ou
les chaumes noël rire même avec des
enfants peut décider tous les soirs
d'aller marcher pendant une demi-heure
une heure là les jim ben oui c'est pour
une catégorie de pays à quelqu'un qui
aime lire c'est à terre que tu dois le
dire moi la du lit en pédalant comme jim
dans ce cas si vous avez tous raison
mais dans ce cas-ci quel exemple donne à
ses enfants
imaginez l'exemple que ses enfants vont
donner à leurs enfants
par la suite il y avait comme une place
mission d'information ici le quai oui
des traditions t on parle de
l'embonpoint chez les gens chez les
enfants on sait elle ne nous a pas dit
que ces enfants faisaient d'embonpoint
cette auditrice françoise de perdus en
france
vous pouvez nous écrire si vous écoutez
en ce moment est-ce que vos enfants sont
gras on sait que la mairie rassembler et
noir écoutez sujet bedonnant mais très
sérieux quand même que ce que les
applications les conséquences sur la
santé à long terme sont sont terribles
oui je vais le savoir ces messieurs des
parties entendent mon émission
parce qu'il fait ça caché dans sa salle
dans sa cuisine est apparu dans son
salon écoutez question question je
promis question jeu de la semaine sur
quel continent
retrouve-t-on le plus grand nombre
d'enfants obèses je pose la question
ah oui au masi l arabe est pas pas mal
quand même en amérique du nord puisque
par les pros pays au monde où il ya plus
d'enfants obèses
il ya les états unis la grèce et le
canada en troisième place nous sommes
troisièmes au niveau mondial outre en
termes de pourcentage de jeunes qui sont
obèses c'est pour ça qu'on en parle
la grèce arrivant deuxième 12e à dire
son nom finalement oui mais vous parlez
des pourcentages la moitié de tous les
enfants obèses dans le monde vivent dans
les pays asiatiques je ne sais pas
combien que le pourcentage en chine
les enfants qui sont qui sont obèses
mais c'est la stat et c'est que j'ai
pour vous grand leader et deuxième
continent dans le monde où il ya plus en
proportion le garder la de d'enfants qui
sont obèses mais non non
enfin ça serait troisième la chance mais
le deuxième c'est sur l asie europe et
commença puis avoir beaucoup de
l'afrique pour des raisons tout à fait
différente quand on est pauvre on est
gras pour d'autres motifs que les pays
riches voilà c'est vrai une autre un
autre mais c'est certainement parce
qu'on voit enfin je termine meilleur et
le pire
hélas non pas assez dans leur assiette
et il ya ceux qui mangent pour montrer
leur opulence et leur richesse c'est
alors question ici je passais tirs et
même d'un artiste que vous avez rédigé
admet arrivant il ya un an et demi en
2013 un rapport de l'unicef sur le
bien-être des enfants dans les pays
riches si c'est le canada donc au
troisième rang et on a une entrevue et
vous proposer jean d'un seul
solomon ancien journaliste ici à radio
canada international oui je veux saluer
en saluant qu'elles n'ont plus n'écoute
pas elle a fait une entrevue et corinne
voyez directrice de la coalition
québécoise sur la problématique du poids
et voici la situation des enfants obèses
au canada les enfants que leurs parents
et leurs grands-parents les plateformes
publicitaires pour la malbouffe par
exemple y en a partout facilement c'est
pas cher des produits comme les boissons
sucrées
c'est des produits qu'on ne voyait pas
se sont multipliées énormément dans les
dernières années des grandes quantités
de ce que l'on retrouve dans ce produit
là et c'est le seul d'ailleurs qui est
associé avec l'obésité et on voit qu'un
énorme marketing alimentaire autour de
ces produits là parmi les autres
solutions que nous on met de l'avant à
la coalition ce sont des politiques
publiques que le gouvernement devra
développer ce n'est de l'encadrement au
niveau du marketing qui devra être fait
réduire les portions par exemple
ample des boissons sucrées présentement
les formes qu'on met de l'avant et un
demi litre qui sur le marché que des
formats énorme
il faudra qu'on voit à essayer de
limiter la présence de sa foudre par
exemple autour des écoles
essayez aussi d'adopter des politiques
qui vont faire en sorte que des enfants
vont pouvoir remarcher pour aller à
l'école que les adultes vont pouvoir se
rendent à pied ou à vélo au travail et
des initiatives de torts de l'ocs
devront être mis de l'avant alors ce
soit que vous qualifiez comme des
stratégies plus efficaces
on le voit très bien que l'éducation
populaire atteint pas le succès qui
devra atteindre
je ne sais faire d'éduquer la population
mais il va falloir qu'on mettre en place
des mesures qui vont permettre de
rejoindre tout le monde de façon égale
et au niveau agroalimentaire la pratique
de l'industrie actuellement extrêmement
agressive pour mettre de l'avant des
produits qui sont pas nécessairement
nutritifs mais très riche en gras en sel
en sucre
je déplace sur lequel des aliments que
les gens vont avoir plus facilement
écouter alors il va falloir encadré
certainement l'industrie alors je vous
promets dans quelques semaines au cours
de l'été probablement
un nouveau dispositif ici en studio ce
sont des lumières qui vont s'allumer
automatiquement dès qu'on va lancer un
nouveau jeu questionnaire exécution sa
serviette alors suffit de développer de
dégager un budget assez importante et
c'est sa deuxième jeu questionnaire des
magies lumière ya pas de trompette mais
presque si vous remportez là vous avez
la bonne réponse sur une sonnerie
particulier sérieuse alors à la fin des
années 1970 le taux d'obésité infantile
au canada se situer à environ quel
pourcentage afin les années 70 chez les
enfants combien que le pourcentage
d'enfants étaient obèses nous pour sa 12
pour cent pour cent moins que ça même
ouais j'ai l'impression que c'est d'être
en bas de 10% en bas de discours sans
jamais dire 23% alors leonardo et oui
vous avez la bonne réponse comment
commencer
oui mais l'offre y est et si et si
nombreuses on avait pas d'aidé des
tablettes on allait les téléphones celle
là n'était pas comme maintenant mais ça
ils passent beaucoup de temps ou ne pas
faire d'exercice à jouer à ces genres de
choses
puis il mangé par en cuisine et un petit
peu plus ce sens sont rapides
elle est là la vie était plus tranquille
alors maman et papa il y avait le temps
basse est surtout maman et abdel tard
pour cuisiner à lens était notre jean
des bouffes que marc arrive c'est une
autre idée tempany à l'époque on était
aussi peut-être un peu plus pauvres
qu'aujourd'hui c'est vrai que les femmes
en sont allés au sont allés massivement
au travail
et la crise économique 2180 au canada
pour ajouter un deuxième revenu parce
que il en arrivait plus et ça coûte très
cher pour se loger par exemple et puis
bon on viendra ce sera le sujet d'une
prochaine émission le coût de la vie je
pense est un très bon sujet alors j'ai
pas terni mon jeu questionnaire des
lumières sont toujours en activité ici
donc 5% en 70 et près de plus de
quarante ans plus tard on peut en parler
maintenant a connaissance de cause n'est
ce pas leonardo week et les pourcentages
des jeunes au canada qui de 3 19 ans qui
souffrent d'obésité de 15 à 20 pour ça
qu'ils avaient pour ça c'est plus comme
je dis j'ai 25 25%
je suis d'accord pour cent à élever
j'allais dire 50% justin ont exercé sur
la rue et vous voyez un enfant sur trois
avouent penser ou un an un sur quatre
dans votre cas penser qu'il est gras
c'est l'image que vous avez des états
unis oui quand on se promène aux états
unis dans les parcs dans les rues des
états unis je voyageais 2
je vois la quantité des enfants
incroyable une différence importante on
voit visuel
il faut aussi définir l'obésité parce
que des fois on vous imagine que justin
surpoids dépendant de ce cri rapporté
dans les médias n'en parlent de beast
aller chercher un dictionnaire pour moi
je n'ai pas reçu de son poids santé
donc si on et grassouillet est-ce qu'on
entre dans cette catégorie les douces on
a tout cela très beau mais je pense que
ce louis est haute à son poids santé
je n'ai pas pensé encore une fois ça
m'arrive tout le temps dans les mairies
clooney dans son pré sensé est
franchement et leoz
cinq kilos de plus que cela il faut
trouver la définition du poisson c'est
quand même 1 5 kg jusque quoi parce
qu'il est hors coûts liés au quotidien
il faut faire il ya une opérationnalité
tic peuvent savoir les poissons c'est
celle à castelletto des gars comme
toujours notre poids santé la limite à
voilà un qui est en est ici autour de la
table moi j'ai dit que j'étais pas mon
poids santé dont je peux je suis passé
de fumeur les hommes reconnaissent
certaines des choses
cette personne a répondu encore
correctement la question parce que la
bonne réponse et transportant des jeunes
gens de 15
créez vous aurez petit peu souvent non
messieurs c'est parce que ben en fait
les sociétés au canada y est le sien
mesures qui ont été prises pour éviter
ces genres de choses par exemple aux
écoles il n'y a pas des consommations de
boissons
supplications et aux états unis
les menus sont mais vraiment créé à la
base je peux ajouter une information il
y en a pas dans les écoles mais souvent
au coin des rues à côté de cet été il ya
tout ce qu'on veut pour mme allemand
absolument mais il faut sens il faut
faire un effort pour les faits mais il
est pas à portée de la main
comme dans d'autres parties du monde il
faut l'installer sur une colline
leonardo mettez le doigt sur quelque
chose de québec est la seule des dix
provinces canadiennes où la publicité à
l'égard des enfants qui dirigeait vers
eux est illégale et on pense ici aux
céréales avec les petits bonshommes très
drôle très amusant au milk dans milk
offrirait un petit personnage en place
c'est qu'un moyen dans l'achat d'un d'un
mec quelque chose je poursuis un rôle à
la la la la boîte la petite boîte pour
les enfants et vient avec un cadeau ah
oui oui vous savez pas comment vous
voyez festin classé dans plusieurs
restaurants rapides cela la majorité
vous offre de publicité dans les médias
dirigés vers les enfants et pas autorisé
le groupe canadien se pencher là dessus
il ya quelques mois qu'on devrait
élargir la sphère au reste du pays
souvent le québec donne l'exemple au
reste du pays
souvent celle inverse mais on n'en parle
pas alors voici un extrait de reportage
qu'on a fait sur cette question du
marketing élargi au canada pour dire non
pas le droit de cibler les enfants
notre invité je pense que l'invité va se
décrire elle même temps qu'un de cet
extrait pour une loi comme ça au canada
depuis très longtemps ça s'appelle la
coalition arrêtons la publicité destinée
aux enfants puis ce groupe là ça fait
c'est tout les organisations non
gouvernementales santé du canada
coalition poids du québec l'association
médicale canadienne et c est tout le
monde supporte à la sénatrice green avec
son projet de loi
monique pots-de-vin kent et professeur
associé à l'école d'épidémiologie et de
santé publique et de médecine préventive
à la faculté de médecine de
université d'ottawa j'applaudis vraiment
concentré je dois ainsi on attend pour
quelque chose comme ça depuis très très
longtemps
le tout réglementation c'est la façon
que ça fonctionne en ce moment à
l'extérieur du québec alors il ya peu
près 16 compagnies qui se sont mises
ensemble 2008 puis ils ont fait des
promesses vis-à-vis le marketing
alimentaire puis que mes recherches
démontrent c'est que l'exposition des
enfants au marketing alimentaire en
effet augmenté depuis que le tour
réglementation commencer au canada puis
que laquelle tine nutritionnels des
publicités x et des enfants a pas changé
tout du tout depuis le début de
l'autoréglementation alors on a vraiment
besoin d'une loi ici au canada pour
protéger les enfants
c'est clair que le tout réglementation
ça fonctionne positif si au québec on
voit de bouc beaucoup davantage avec la
loi sur la protection du consommateur
alors au québec par exemple sur les
postes enfants il ya moins de volume en
termes d'annoncés publicitaires pour la
malbouffe
ayew 6 beaucoup beaucoup de produits
convoque on ne voit jamais jamais sur
les postes enfants puis les produits
dangereux
c'est comme les lycées rial très sucrées
comme faust flakes kwan porte des choses
comme ça les collations traîtresse qsi
qui cible les enfants comme est ce que
vous connaissez les produits fruits au
long c'est un produit comme ça on le
voit souvent à la télé un sur l'internet
à l'extérieur du québec mais au québec
c'est pas des produits qu'on voit des
trucs tout du tout
1 pour ce qui est de la publicité de ce
qu'on pourrait faire pour éloigner les
enfants de ce qui n'est pas bon
notamment le sucre leonardo qui se
trouvent partout véritable industrie
comme l'armement des commerces et le
journal le même chiffre d'affaires que
les armes puis la drogue aux stations
essence et ça c'est légal tout à fait
légale ll et surtout oui oui absolument
puis si on transformait je vais parler
autour d'un documentaire s'appelle fidh
ap
si vous le temps et ce serait bien de
les voir et feed api qui s'appelle en
fait qui parle d industrie qui est
commun
même l'industrie du sucre y a changé les
plans des madame obama qui quand il a
commencé à faire c'était comme j'ai pour
f1 éviter en fait les enfants avec des
problèmes santé pour ça oui
puis les l'industrie et de ceux qui y
arias désirons bafa comme vous madame
obama on va vous aider peas ont appuyé
madame obama avec de l'argent qu'ils ont
changé toutes les slogans finalement les
lille les aliments sucrés sont vendus
dans les écoles c'est vraiment
incroyable
j'ai une autre question pour vous à
laquelle vous n'êtes pas obligé de
répondre honnêtement
alors voici la question on a déjà vu
ensemble que la plupart d'entre nous
nous le fait que nous ne sommes pas
notre poids santé
[Rires]
c'est le fond de la bouteille marie la
question quand vous étiez jeune et
scanner ici la main levé la main si dans
votre jeunesse vous avez été se vit un
peu trop de prix pour un mois donné ou
un autre ça peut-être à l'adolescence
pendant quelques années celle qu qui
s'ajustait en fait voilà ça arrive
souvent à balai est fini je trouve que
ça arrive quand même souvent comme entre
dans l'adolescence c'est mon cas oui oui
alors c'est un peu normal de passer à
travers ça je pense que des fois on
exagère bon mais je me rappelle quand
j'avais 11 ans je suis revenu d'afrique
et je me suis mis aux patates frites ou
mets abondants qui n'existait pas en
afrique que j'en buvais par des galons
et je pris du poids d'un était là c'est
épouvantable et des photos de moi un
petit garçon grand monsieur gros
monsieur
et puis mon père qui aimait pas s'amuser
pas dire parce qu'un père aime son fils
mais veut pas lui faire de peine et sa
solution sans me dire non et suivent des
cours de judo à ça a commencé par deux
fois par semaine c'était comme ça puis
si j allais pas y aller
même à la maison qu'est ce que tu as dit
que tu que tu veux pas le faire trop
judo sa mamie ça m'a sorti de maison
c'est moi je reste à la maison que je
mange et je puis c'est délicat ces
problèmes là et c'était fois de plus
normal de passer à travers des phases et
prendre un peu de poids puis ensuite de
l'axé mais sa cause des problèmes et
l'école et je sais le dernier thème
qu'on abhorre abordent ensemble est-ce
que vous pensez que c'est parmi les
trois les trois possibilités est-ce que
c'est véritablement en lambeau point qui
est la plus grande cause d'intimidation
à l'école ou sur la couleur de la peau
ou l'orientation sexuelle ici même au
québec l embonpoint
non pour moi tout ça c'est sûr c'est
vrai mais je me souviens jeunes à
l'école que effectivement les personnes
qui avaient un peu plus de poids était
assise et se sentent plus que par
rapport au dos aux autres donc exempts
jeu dont vous n'avez pas le souvenir
soit juste s'est vérifié encore
aujourd'hui c'est ça oui c'est encore ça
c'est une enquête qui était faite par
l'association québécoise pour la santé
publique la cuvée est sans nulle as pas
qu plutôt lent à la q ps ainsi pas moins
de 90 % des avc sont interrogés par les
chercheurs québécois récemment la disent
avoir été témoin d' intimidation par
rapport au surpoids deux de leurs amis à
l'école alors ça c'est un grave problème
d'intimidation on en parle beaucoup mais
on a peu parlé de la question de
l'embonpoint lorsqu'on faisait ses
campagnes contre l'intimidation
on pointe pas du doigt lambert - c'est
très délicat de parler de l'embonpoint
désir de critiquer ça mais ce qu'il
faudrait
ce dont il faudrait parler aussi c'est
qu'on peut être un petit peu plus gros
qu'à la norme mettrait en santé aussi ça
peut être mettre notre code génétique
qui fait qu'on soit comme ça parce qu'on
ne soit pas toujours associé un bon
point à mauvaise au mauvais mode de vie
oui sauf qu'à l'école primaire au
secondaire ce qu'on regarde c'est les
gens qui sont différents de nous et
c'est la différence a souvent qui fait
qu' on est
et on va voter oui on attire l'attention
oui et bouger mais quand j'étais jeune
j'aimais beaucoup ce qui était très
athlétique je les enviais de sauter de
courir
j'étais toujours dans le 60 % alors que
j'aurais rêvé dans le 90 % 1 parce qu'on
n'a pas une érection admiration devant
ce qu'ils sont plus flexibles plus
rapide
je pense que ça joue quelque part dans
nos valeurs on a préparé donc cet
extrait tiré encore une fois de notre
coffre fort au trésor de radio canada
international identique de fond qui ne
disent pas qu'ils visent très bien pour
il voici donc il ya deux spécialistes
qui sont interdits et je pense dans cet
extrait ils sont les identifie le jeune
est en surpoids mais c'est sans doute de
faire des progrès et paul quoi mais ce
qui est quand même cri de détresse des
tragiques en cédant la loi 56 on
mentionne des caractéristiques physiques
donc j'en déduis cas des
caractéristiques physiques inclut le
poids et le surpoids
par contre on le mentionne pas estimant
alors vous avez que les taux d'accès qui
a été conduite avec l'association de la
santé publique du québec
viser à mettre 200 revient le fait que
c'est une préoccupation vraiment bien
présente dans les cours d'école au
secondaire et qu'on devrait donc garder
faute du prg est peut-être même songé à
l'incurie ses mains comme on fait avec
la distance intellectuels ou des
problèmes physiques ou d'autres types de
caractères et ce dernier avec les dom et
inondations les enfants n'ont pas oublié
comment jouer un enfant sera toujours
comment jouer c'est peut-être plus à
haut niveau du rôle de l'adulte qui est
qui a évolué dernièrement où l'adulte
veut toujours occuper ses enfants faut
toujours que lui et un intérêt pour le
jeu de l'enfant qui lie
qui dirige un petit peu l'entièreté de
la vie de l'enfant et elle n'est pas à
l'aise en fait avec le fait que l'enfant
joue tout seul et puis jouer à un tube
qui veut mathieu points et professeur au
département des sciences de l'éducation
de l'université du québec à trois
rivières une ville située entre montréal
et québec
c'est vraiment contre l adulte qui
initie jeu pour l'enfant qui prépare une
activité c'est lui qui a en charge un
petit peu et l'enfant ne fait que suivre
les instructions de l'adulte quand on
parle de jeux libres c'est un petit peu
ce que ce que certains auteurs
considèrent comme le vrai jeu entre
guillemets le jeu où l'enfant décide par
lui-même à quoi il va jouer avec quoi il
va jouer où il va jouer et avec qui va
jouer c'est lui qui est mettre un petit
peu de sa situation de jeu et plusieurs
études démontrent que c'est lors du jeu
lire que l'enfant est plus active
ce manque d'activité physique c'est chez
les jeunes mais c'est directement lié
avec un manque de jeux libres un petit
peu actuellement les enfants s'en sont
très structurés dans leurs activités
tuellement on est dans une société qui
est qui est vraiment poussé vers la
performance dans l'excellence et c'est
donc les parents ont tendance à vouloir
à tout prix que leurs enfants sachent
lire écrire des plus jeune âge mais
quand on connaît un petit peu les les
phases de développement de l'enfant mais
on se rend compte que trop tôt c'est pas
forcément du bon que en bas âge jusqu'à
5-6 ans le jeu libre est vraiment
favorable au développement de l'enfant
plus que le déclic est structurée nous
amène donc
vers la fermeture avec la question
d'ouverture nos enfants ajoutent ils
encore dehors
et vous comment je vais vous poser la
question moi j'adore et d'or j'attends
pas le printemps pour les doors je suis
dehors tout divers j'aime la pâte est
jamais ski de fond j'aime le jogging
divers qu'il était en plus on peut
rajouter le vélo on rajoute la natation
alors moi j'ai aucun problème à jouer
tant le jeu s'en servir la santé de
votre côté mais j'ai remarqué que c'est
plutôt une sorte d un réflexe nordiques
c'est que quand surtout quand c'est la
fin de semaine quand il fait beau
si on sort pas c'est quasiment
criminelle
si tu restes dans la maison il ya un
problème parce qu'il faisait beau
d'arteta perdre une occasion ici
les enfants notre somme arrivons vous
avez une belle grande fille êtes
impliqué dans sa vie à tous à tous les
échelons beaucoup plus que d'autres par
un je pense est-ce que vous jouez avec
elle dort on fait du vélo ensemble
l'hiver on fait du ski de fond ont fait
du patin on va jouer au badminton
elle est fait de la danse en plus alors
oui on joue beaucoup à un terrain de
tennis pas loin de chez nous dans ma
joue au tennis même si je suis pourri
c'est pas grave on s'amuse on marche
beaucoup alors oui et leonardo votre
patron vous impose une tâche de travail
intenables
est-ce que vous avez encore le temps
d'aller jouer avec vos enfants d'un oui
pas trop mais oui en fait jadis est
jamais loin
alors quand j'arrive les enfants sont en
train de faire ses devoirs puis après il
n'y a pas beaucoup de terre parce que
marge en fait c'était comme si c'est oui
au début c'est une question d'état mais
comment on priorise les choses ni comme
un os mais ça pour pouvoir profiter les
plus très bien et moi non je n'ai pas le
temps de jouer avec les enfants jamais
jamais le temps je n'en ai pas non mais
vous avez un grand terrain sur lequel
vous allez jouer où elle travaille et je
joue comme un enfant sa garde en forme
moi je voulais vous dire on a ajouté sur
notre page de tintin canada un autre
sujet qui accompagnent notre discussion
tous les thèmes abordés aujourd'hui sont
détaillés à plus de détails on peut
passer je pense une heure ou deux à lire
ce qu'on a préparé et on a dû passants
qui nous ont écrit et il faut que je
quitte une nouvelle allure vous c'est
notre ligne teilhet puy mahb acide au
sein hr est dit en anglais au prince un
god and informatif c'est gentil ça et on
s'exprime assez clairement pour être
bien compris j'imagine en anglais ce qui
est fantastique quand je suis ainsi à
côté des coq mes copains espagnol je
comprends tout j'ose pas leur dire il ya
je pense seulement mais je comprends
leurs amphis par les comprendre être
merci beaucoup
oui ou des de la section chinoise de
radio canada international d'être venu
ici aujourd'hui
al marri vent qui n'appartenait plus à
ercis qui appartenait maintenant
radio-canada ou serveuse au service foot
ça passe mal dans ma boîte à fun
vous savez sans doute agi parce que tout
est parti ça me fait de la peine mais
vous êtes lot vendredi plaisir leonardo
di mino grâce à vous merci à vous et
puis marie-claude sort bientôt grâce à
vous ce sera parce que techniquement
d'avoir 30 ans canada vous allez mettre
leonardo dehors permet dé la mission les
jarres me suis soulagé la commune je
sais pas si une note spéciale de vos
parents qui ont autorisé votre présence
à ce jeu les pièces a été envoyée aux
chefs des pupitres pierre messieurs
c'est fantastique d'administration merci
beaucoup à tous badaling bonne semaine
la semaine prochaine